we're on problem 237
a part-time employee whose hourly wage
was increased by 25 percent decided to
reduce the number of hours worked per
week so that the employee's total weekly
income would remain unchanged
by what percent
should the number of hours worked be
reduced
so before he made his wage
his hourly wage times hours worked right
this is what he would normally work and
let's see his weekly in a week right so
his wage per hour times hours per week
this is what he used to make but now
what he's done is since he's making 25
more of his wage so he's making 25 more
of his wage he's going to reduce his
hours by some number
by some fraction right let's call that x
so then that so then the new wage times
the new hours
and they're saying that he doesn't want
to change the total amount that he makes
in a week
so the new age times the new hours will
equal w times h let's divide both sides
by w
this goes to 1 that goes to 1. divide
both sides by h that goes to 1. that
goes to 1. and you're left with 1 is
equal to
1.25
times x
and i view that this is easier to think
of as what five-fourths
right 1.25 right four-fourths is one
and then you add another four this is
one and fourth so this is 5 4. so let's
write that as 5 4 x multiply both sides
by four fifths you get x is equal to
four fifths which is equal to 0.8
so another way to view it is he would
reduce he's working 80 percent of the
hours that he used to work so he reduced
reduced by 20 percent the amount that he
worked and that will be choice
b
next problem 238
okay they've drawn us a figure
so let's draw the figure
let's
let me see if i could
make it thicker
okay so they drew a box in a box
then there's another box in that box and
it looks something like that
and then
they shaded it in so i'll shade it in
and they say that this side up here
is 18
and they say that this side over here is
15.
the shaded region in the figure above
represents a rectangular frame with
length 18 inches and width 15 inches
the frame encloses a rectangular picture
that has the same
area as the frame itself
so this area is equal to this area
fascinating
if the length in which and if the length
and width of the picture have the same
ratio as the length and width of the
frame
what is the length
of the picture
in inches
so they're saying that this is the
length so this is l
this is the length
and this is the width and they want us
to solve for
l right what is the length of the
picture right there they're calling i
mean i would call that width but they
say originally say the frame with length
18 inches so they want to know the
length of the picture okay first of all
they tell us that the ratios are the
same
so l to w
of the picture is the same ratio as it
is for the frame is
18 to 15. if you divide by 3 that's the
same thing as 6 to 5 right l to w is
equal to 6 to 5. now the other thing
they told us that the area
of the picture is the same as the area
of the frame so the area of the picture
is l
times w and what's the area of the frame
we'll see area of this whole thing which
is 15
times 18
minus the area of the picture right
because the area of the frame is not
this whole rectangle it's just the part
that doesn't have a picture in it so
minus
l times w
so if we add lw to both sides we get
lw is equal to 15 times 18. i'm just
going to leave that as 15 times 18.
15 times 18.
let's see we could already divide both
sides by 2. so you get l w is equal to
15 times 9
15 times
9.
and let's see we have two equations with
two unknowns let's see if we can solve
so we have
l over w is equal to six over five we
can cross multiply so we get five
l is equal to six w i ignored this stuff
in the middle
and we want to solve for l right so
let's substitute for w so we get
over 6 l is equal to w and now let's
substitute that into this equation
so we have l times w which is 5 over 6 l
times 5 over 6 l is equal to 15
times 9
and let's see let's multiply both tides
by 6 over 5 and so you would get
l squared is equal to fifteen
times nine times six over five times six
over
five
so let's see we could do a little
simplification this becomes
three
this becomes one
and then we have let's see now we have
to do some math
so what's to see if we have 3 times 9 is
27 27
times 6
27 times 6 is what 6 times
7 times 6 is 42
2 times 6
is 12 plus 4 is 161
that's a that's a strange number
so let's see let's see if i can simplify
this oh i'm looking at choices they have
all sorts of crazy square roots in it so
let's say let's just say that l is equal
to
the square root
of
let's see how can we rewrite this we
could we could rewrite the 6 as 3 times
2 right
and so then we get
3 times 9 times 3 that's the same thing
as 9 times 9 that's 81 right
81 times 2 and then we have a 1 in the
denominator
so l is equal to
and i'll do it one more step because i
think this confuses a lot of people
that's equal to the square root of 81
times the square root of 2 which is
equal to
9 square roots of 2 which is choice a
problem 239
of the 200 students at college t
majoring in one or more of the sciences
i already feel a venn diagram coming on
of the 200 students at college team
majoring in one or more of the sciences
130 are majoring so let me draw the
whole well let me look read the whole
problem 130 are majoring in chemistry
and 150 are majoring in biology if at
least 30 of the students are not
majoring in either chemistry or biology
then the number of students majoring in
both chemistry and biology can be any
number from okay let me draw the venn
diagram
so that's chemistry
that's biology
and then
then there's a leftover right this is a
whole pool
so they tell us there's 200 total right
this 200 total
and they say that 130 are majoring in
chemistry
in biology
and then at least 30 of the students are
not majoring in either chemistry or
biology so we could say greater than or
equal to 30. so this is this is adding a
little spin here by making it an
inequality then the number of students
majoring in both chemistry and biology
could be
any number
from
okay so let's say let's say that this is
30 just to simplify our thinking if this
is 30 how many people are majoring in
chemistry or biology
well then it's 170 right
so let's think of it this way let's
think of this as the intercept this is
both well we already used b for biology
so let's call this
i don't know let's call this
y c for combined so let's call this i
for the intersection
right
so if 30 people are majoring in
in
well actually let's just call this x
right
so how many people are majoring in if i
wanted to add these two numbers up if i
want to know the people who are in
chemistry or biology what would it be
it would be
plus 150
and remember we've done this a couple of
times with these venn diagram problems
if i counted these 130 and then i count
these 130 of these 150 i've counted this
intersection twice i counted it with the
130 and i counted it with 150. so i have
to subtract out at least the
intersection once so i subtract it out
once so these are the number of people
who are in chemistry or biology or both
right so it's the intersection chemistry
or biology or both
and now we know that that has got to be
equal to
that has got to be equal to what
well 200 minus the people who are in
nothing right so i'm going to call that
x for now
minus the people who are nothing
and let's see if we can solve for the
intersection which is what they're
asking us in terms of x so this becomes
minus i
is equal to 200
minus x
and then they tell us to subtract 200
from both sides you get 80
minus i is equal to minus x let's add i
to both sides so you get 80
is equal to
i
minus x
right well even better let's let's add x
to both sides so you get i
is equal to
plus
x
right
i is equal to 80 plus x
and so if x is greater than or equal to
so we know that i
has to if x is 30 then we get what we
get a 100
30 plus 80 is a 110 right so we know
that i is going to be greater than or
equal to
right
the intersection
is at least 110.
now what's an upper bound on it how many
people can be studying both and if you
look at the choices already there's two
choices that have 110 is the minimum for
the number of studying both what's the
maximum that can be studying both
well it's 130 right if all of the
chemistry people are also studying
biology then the intersection becomes
right but you can't have 150 people
studying both because there's only 150
studying chemistry
so the intersection is greater than or
equal to 110 and it's limited by the
number of people studying chemistry 130
which is choice
d
and i'll see you in the next video